[Music]
joining me today is the founder of the
American conservation Coalition an
organization committed to efficient
effective conservative environmentalism
hashtag green GOP Benji backer
welcome to the Rubin reports great to be
here I feel you are long overdue
even though twenty years old you didn't
have a lot of time to get here but you
know you got here we've met a couple
times I kind of found out about you a
couple years ago we're gonna talk about
what kind of put you on the map in the
political world and got your activism
going and all that but it's good to have
you here I like that you you dressed
ready for the party oh yeah you gotta
gotta look good to feel good alright so
you have a really interesting story of
what got you in this mix but first I
just thought I'd like to ask my guests
just kind of tell me a little bit about
your upbringing yeah Emily that kind of
thing
yeah so I grew up in a family of five
completely non-political very close
family we traveled a lot together
youngest I had two older sisters my
parents were actually entrepreneurs they
started a business when I was I want to
say ten which was a software company
based on mortgages and really started to
take off but it was during the recession
and it was a really bold move for that
time mind it really paid off and they're
now retired and kind of lived the
American dream which was a really cool
thing to be brought up by yeah what
about the politics at home were you guys
always kind of conservative or it didn't
talk about it so actually you've got
really different views my sister is a
liberal one of them and then one
is more just not into it very much my
parents are conservative but they never
told us really about their views they
wanted us to decide for ourselves
obviously their morals and values I
think played into how I feel about
things but it was never forced upon us
or they were not adamant about politics
or volunteered or donated to my
knowledge to campaigns so it really
wasn't talked about in the house you
know they'd have the debates on or
they'd you have the news on but nothing
really more than that so I was able to
figure out my opinions for myself when I
was a little bit earlier than most
people when I was 10 but yeah what kind
of opinions does a ten-year-old have why
was Washington John McCain
Obama debates which 10 years old yes at
10 years old I found it really
interesting and I wanted to figure out
where I stood on the spectrum of what I
support John McCain or what I support I
think Senator Obama at the time yeah and
so I looked up online kind of just a
basic outline of what each side believed
in and I figured out that I was
conservative and so for that couple
years I kind of I I forced my parents to
put signs in our yard for John McCain I
forced them to put bumper stickers on
our cars
what are you various what did your
parents think about this they're 10
you're like all right well support you
in whatever you do they were very I mean
it's it's I think that they were
surprised and I I don't know if any
parent thinks that their 10 year old kid
is gonna get super interested in
politics because it doesn't really
affect you at 10 years old it doesn't
really affect you until after college
really so that was kind of a surprise to
them but they were supportive they let
me you know research as much as I wanted
to and again they allowed me to put the
signs in the yard the bumper stickers on
my RipStik you know that type of thing
so it was a pretty cool time and then I
got injured and decided to volunteer
because I couldn't play sports no all
right so I would I want to get to that
in a sec but wait I just want a picture
there's 10 years old you're watching me
you guys soon you're watching with your
folks probably er yeah right ok you go
online to figure out the issues what
mattered to you at 10 years old that you
said at the end of it ok I'm a
conservative or I'm gonna vote for
McCain well my pet my parents were
always really fiscally
be conservative was just how they spent
money you know we were never like in a
really really tough position when I was
super young but we always were saying
you know buy the cheapest product you
can save as much money as you can
and that was something that I was
brought up with so that really mattered
to me and knowing that the government
could take away my parents hard earned
money and knowing that the government
could come in and and harm my dad's
business by putting a ton of
restrictions that kind of struck me
pretty harshly and then also my family
we were raised on family values right
you know close-knit family it kind of
happens that way so those two things
were kind of the main drivers I would
say yeah it's just hard to imagine a ten
year old is but it's at but it's pretty
cool and it explains why you're here
right now so okay what put you on the
map and when I found out about you and I
think nationally when people found out
about you and now this makes sense now
that I know that this was brewing a ten
year ago 2013 you're 15 years old yeah
what happened yeah so I had been active
in politics for three years before that
and what does that even mean well I was
gone
carry on Scott Walker's campaign Senator
Ron Johnson scam pain I helped out Mitt
Romney as well in 2012 and people
believe it started throw up but could
people even believe it like here's this
12 year old kid 11 year old kid working
on these campaigns actually funny the
first campaign ever worked on did let me
use the phones at first because they
could you know we need to try to do a 12
year old on the pill you can tell us
like hi is Michael yes yeah they're like
yeah but like who are you and why are
you 12 and why are you calling me from a
congressional office through a channel
campaign and so people were actually
really surprised conservatives were
really supportive they're like whoa look
at this 12 year old kid is volunteering
for us and the left is like why is this
12 year old and cheering for them so it
was pretty funny again I was injured so
I needed something to do in like any
twelve-year-old I decided to volunteer
for politics so yeah it's a very
interesting dynamic because this is also
hilarious that an injury got you into
politics what what kind of injury was an
ankle injury that the
doctors couldn't figure out I was on
crutches for a year and a half Wow
gained a lot of weight
it was during middle school which does
not help because those are the worst
years for that anyways and so then again
I went into congressional office and
they didn't want me to do the phones
they didn't want me to go door-to-door
cuz imagine the 12 year olds coming to
your door like hey you should vote for X
Y or Z like I might why should I trust a
12 year old right so this is a very
interesting dynamic at that age so
alright so now what puts you on the map
yes 13 years 15 years old something
happens yes so in high school early on
in high school and middle school
teachers had really come out for me for
my political views because I was trying
to make local headlines for my activism
especially in the recall election for
Scott Walker in 2012 mom so tell me that
tell me a little bit about what your
opinions were and what your teachers
were yes I was really Pro Scott Walker
guy I was I actually ended up becoming
close with his family and then and a
great guy but I even better policies you
know I talked to a lot of teachers who
were sick of being forced to join unions
and sick of starting out with $30,000
base pay when senior senior teachers
were making $100,000 with benefits mm-hm
and it took them 40 years to get to that
level even if they're a better teacher
so people were really kind of sick of
that but it was a very small minority
because the unions really had a lot of
brainwashing in the state and I'm sure
in other states as well and so my view
is that Scott Walker is really helping
out the state because he helped balance
the budget and he kind of freed the
teachers up and helped their pay become
more of a fair shake but they the
teachers did not like that the majority
of them I mean most people know of the
huge uprising that happened the protests
were there are thousands of people death
threats to every Republican in the state
legislature and the governor and so the
teachers would leave school they
protested they take leave they would cry
in class I mean it was it was pretty
insane yeah and then you know you have
me over here bald little Benjy going out
there and saying Scott Walker they did
not like that at all so they would say
pretty disparaging things to be in class
in front of my like what kind of things
would they say to you there
my family for being business owners and
saying that they were lazy and saying
that they assumed that my parents golf
every Friday by the way my parents don't
know how to golf so that's not true
I don't know how I golf and so that was
that was one thing that that uh that
they would always say and they would
call me a racist or weird for being in
politics at such a young age what's that
like for for a kid of that age I'd be
dealing with that it's one thing to be
outspoken but I hope your teachers your
authority figures are attacking you
publicly in school I actually had a
minute rank than me because at first I
was pretty taken aback and I was kind of
sad about it but my parents really
pushed me on and said you're doing the
right thing and just kind of block out
as the Millennials say block out the
haters yeah so I I didn't really care
that much as long as it didn't affect my
grades or how my classmates viewed me
because I do care about the people that
I am friends with so so that was kind of
frustrating but after a while I just
kind of got used to it because it would
happen in a class every single quarter
of every single semester of every single
year seventh grade until til I started
coming out nationally about this issue
did it ever affect your grades because I
could see a teacher in a subjective
class maybe not math where it would be
tough to screw with your grades but a
social studies teacher where you're
writing an essay or an English teacher
or something actually harming your grade
it did actually my lowest grade ever was
in a social studies class in middle
school I've never gotten anything really
below like a high B level and there I
got a d-plus Wow in that social studies
class its middle school so at that point
was middle school so generally matter
per se but you could say you could see
that there was a trend going and that
I'd be worried in the future years
whether or not that it would affect me
and in other classes I don't think it
did as much which is good but in that
class I did see I mean it's a pretty
obvious correlation between me getting
good grades in every class since that in
every class before then and then getting
a d-plus in that class right not weird
and also probably not a coincidence that
social studies is the class that you
were probably talking about this
right most right did you did you try to
fight the teacher on that did your folks
get involved or anything oh we actually
I actually ended up switching schools
Wow I mean it's incredible yeah so so
that was that was a big change it
actually ended up being for the better
because the school switch to is one the
feeder school to the high school that I
was going to so I ended up making better
connections there but it was an annoying
change that shouldn't have been
necessary it was a teacher who had a
history of these types of behaviors not
just on politics but on other things so
so it's interesting because you were
fighting the unions which in your
estimation was actually Pro teacher
because you felt the unions were too
powerful I mean while you have teachers
fighting you which is really only
feeding your initial premise right in
the first place yeah so that was really
it really enhanced my opinion on the
subject it made me really want to to
push further because I could tell that
some of these teachers were really
worried about their job or their job
security because they knew that they
could actually be held accountable now
man some of the senior teachers knew
that oh I actually have to perform well
to get paid well I don't my age isn't
just the deciding factor yeah so I think
that's why people came out so strongly
in certain areas so some people just
didn't really understand the full scope
of the situation and call him down once
they figured that out but some I think
were really worried about their their
future pay because they had kind of just
been relaxed for the last twenty years
since their pay had gone up right so
basically they weren't doing a great job
and rice isn't just unique to Wisconsin
this is happen all over America where
you have these teachers that have been
at it forever I've kind of given up or
are not working that hard anymore but
they're protected by the unions their
salaries keep going up they get great
benefits etc etc that's what you're
fighting and you're seeing the the
fruits of what happens with that as
they're cracking down on you so what
actually put you on what was the
specific incident that that put this all
in motion yeah so I kind of took all the
information that I had of all the
experiences that I had gone through and
wrote it up in a blog for Freedom Works
it ended up going to Drudge and then
Todd Starnes at Fox wrote something up
about it
Town Hall had something it started to
get in that space and then eventually
Megyn Kelly's show reached out to ask me
to come on and talk about it
so that kind of put me on the map there
and then I started to be invited to
conferences to speak about my experience
and kind of how other young
conservatives shouldn't be scared to
speak out in the classroom even if their
teachers or other fellow students come
after them
it wasn't easy because it was my
sophomore year of high school actually
my fresh end of my freshman year of high
school and the after that Fox News
interview I received death threats
people were threatening me at school
because some of the teachers that I had
called out which I never named their
names but I called them out they were
popular with the students so people
weren't happy about it
so it was it was not an easy time for my
family either
yeah I want to focus on that a little
bit but I think because everyone gets
this these days and rice is one of the
themes of what we do here is everyone's
just like afraid to say anything because
they don't want a deal they don't want
to deal with just the hate they get on
Twitter and you got plenty of that and
that's how I found you after this but
but the other stuff like you had to go
to school the next day so literally what
what is that like well I I don't have
ever said this publicly but I carried a
knife at a school so he's so scared with
my life and I didn't tell my parents I
had a friend give it to me that was
worried about my safety it was a pretty
hard time because no matter if people
think I was doing something right or
wrong I think part of the problem with
our culture and it was the same way for
years ago or five years ago is that if
someone's doing something you don't
agree with you're just gonna completely
attack them wholeheartedly without any
respect for what they're doing or their
opinions or anything like that and so I
was honestly scared for my life you know
I couldn't go anywhere I got my bike
stolen when I bike to an ice cream shop
and I live in a very safe place and it
was somebody from my high school that
just really didn't like me you know I'd
be walking my dogs and someone would
flip me off and say after you Benjy
backer you know suck up whatever what
about your family at that time because I
know you said your folks were always
backing you and telling you right do
what you believe in was there any
repercussions for them or their business
or anything like that no their business
was fine I think you know most most
adults who knew what was going on
treated me with a lot of respect I think
it is mostly the young people who who
were a little bit ignorant about what
was going on so my parents didn't have
any negative repercussions that I
no of again they might have been not
telling me because they didn't want to
make it any worse for me because they
don't know that I care about them so
that was that was a tough time for them
though because they live through their
kids and having something like that the
constantly going after our people
constantly going after your son is not
the greatest thing in the world
especially when they know that what
you're doing is right so they were
coming by biggest supporters at the time
telling me to keep pushing on and you
know again bluff the haters and just
kind of and do what you think is right
because at the end of the day people are
gonna realize it eventually and I had
tons of people come after or come up to
me and years afterwards and apologize
and realize that what they did was
immature people who said the worst
thanks to me or told me to kill myself
or whatever those people would come up
to me and say I'm really sorry because
people mature they start to realize that
that's not OK dialogue even if you
totally disagree to someone so yeah
sadly we have a lot of people who don't
mature these sounds but that is that is
not right here though what about the
support you got from you guys I mean
where your where your friends that
supported you willing to publicly
support you because that's enough see
that's another there's there are certain
things that's why I think this is so
interesting there are certain trends
with all of these whether it's you
taking an unpopular but principled
position or it's a guy like Brett
Weinstein at Evergreen there's all these
different people that come out come out
I mean it's a coming out in the way that
the same tactics happen every time and
in this case the idea that your your
friends or whatever won't back you
publicly but privately probably had no
problem doing it yeah I had friends who
came up to me or text me saying I
support you and I feel terrible for what
you're going through but I can't
associate myself with you and those
friends ended up trying to associate
with me later on in a way those are the
worst ones right because it's like if
someone just tells you to go after
yourself it's like big deal ok whatever
but the friends it's like am i your
shield am i you know gonna be like am i
the guy that's supposed to just be out
there while you sit quietly and do
nothing you're not helping me right yeah
I had one really good friend named
Brandon who supported me through it all
and would come over every this death
threat stuff started to happen right as
summer started which was
the worst time is in high school as a
freshman you don't really do anything
during summer so you're just like at
home sitting looking at your Twitter
thing you know all these people want to
kill me
or they think I'm the worst person in
the world so it's really nice to have
you know one friend who I could rely on
plus my family
yeah I actually took a little bit of a
break from the town that I lived in my
dad even said you know things got worse
that we couldn't move if that was
necessary which I never thought it was
gonna be necessary it never was but I
took a little bit of a break and it went
to my grandparents house for a while
just to get away from it all because
there was one time actually at my house
when well the two times once when
someone called and said they were gonna
come to my house and kill me
she's not an anonymous line to my home
phone and then a second time when I was
watching a movie and it was actually Ted
and I was trying to like have a fun
night and after all this stuff had been
going on and the someone knocked on the
window and was like flipping me off and
this is like in the middle of the night
because I was sitting in my living room
so I was pretty scared to be at home for
a little while and so I went away for a
little bit yeah and it's interesting
because I don't want to belabor the
point with you and there's a lot of
other that's the important stuff I want
to talk about but I think that it's
worth mentioning just because so many
people go through this and more
importantly you're on the other side now
yeah you made it you're doing cool stuff
and you survived that it's just worth
showing people that yeah well usually
you will survive yeah and I think you
know what was really big for me is that
it takes a strong person to go through
that but there are tons of people going
through the exact same thing nationwide
and I would even say that there are some
people on the left side who go through
the exact same thing because it's not
just it's not just people on the left
you have this nasty attitude it's people
on the right as well and I think it's
it's sickening because even if you just
use someone wholeheartedly just stay
quiet if you really if you really are
gonna be that rude and that upset about
it be respectful or be quiet that's kind
of how I would like to view things and
so I think to other people who are in
similar situations persevering through
this is the best thing that you can go
through I mean I I feel like I'm matured
into a 45 or 50 year old I was like 14
or 15 years old so
I was able to really progress and I
think it actually might be one of the
best experiences of my life even though
it's the one of the worst experiences in
my life in terms of furthering myself it
was one of the best and I also think
just knowing that if I can persevere
through it anyone can and anyone should
and standing up for your viewpoints
isn't gonna be easy but it's totally
worth it well said you know I think we
talked about this while we had lunch a
couple weeks ago yeah and I think we
talked about this but I told you that I
think my best professional moment is
also my worst professional moment and it
was when larry elder just bludgeoned be
over the head with facts and it was my
worst cuz i wasn't prepared it was my
best because it opened me up right and
then I was like oh new information new
facts let's let's explore that so so
yeah getting through something is pretty
beautiful not that I'm comparing that
moment with Larry - yeah and I think
what I found is that it actually what I
did open up the eyes of a lot of people
who attacked me right they event
eventually apologized and if they want
to attack me and apologize they want to
have open their minds either you know a
couple years later they're probably
thinking back like oh wow you know that
was really a terrible of me but would
they ever have thought about that if
that won't have happened they might have
done the same thing five years later it
would be way worse than doing it in high
school so I think that going through
those experiences in our what side
you're on is better and I don't think
that it should happen but it does it
does help you persevere yeah so that
moment puts you on the map now you know
I started following you on Twitter
everywhere all these people are
following you you're suddenly your voice
is being heard were you immediately
involved in more activism after that or
I see then it's you had an interesting
phase of like sort of I could tell you
were like very frustrated with politics
at times and you were pissed at your own
side a lot and and you know and Trump
and all that flashing forward a little
bit later but what we got what was the
next step was just get us to to where
you're right now yes I think I dealt
with so much negative political
experiences that there's so many
negative political experiences that I
wanted to do something positive and I
was sick of the partisan bickering on
both sides you know I've I have not
really changed on any of my beliefs I
think both sides have just gone further
and further away from the middle
is frustrating so I actually took a year
hiatus in high school my senior year
just to enjoy school and join my friends
and kind of graduate with with a fun
last experience but I couldn't really
stay away as long as hi had hoped I was
thinking that I could probably stay away
through college as well yeah but I had
seen so many negative things that there
needed to be something done that was
positive and I was so you know again
sick of the partisan bickering that I
wanted to to get involved in something
that would benefit society and have a
decent dialogue and won't generate
complete hate from both sides and I
think that we need more of that in
politics a decent dialog and if it has
to has to happen on an easy entry issue
like the environment which is what I
focus on then so be it but I would hope
that that could transfer over to really
hotly contested issues - like gun
control or immigration right by the way
I would argue that actually talking
about the environment can be perhaps the
most hotly contested because anytime
anytime I've done anything on climate on
this show the amount of hate is bananas
on both sides no itch of course it
shouldn't be right well we are all
living on this planet Earth so we all
care about it I would say help yeah
that's majority of us it's a matter of
what you think is the best way to care
about it but whoa Kay so we're gonna get
to all your your work that's the answer
so now I should be about is how we all
care about it but let's talk about the
different solutions yeah okay so before
we get to the solutions and what you're
doing now yeah what else I think what
people see a young conservative there's
still a piece of them that they don't
know what to make sense of that how
would you describe conservatism in 2018
you gave me a little bit of sort of what
your initial thoughts on it were when
you were 10 but right now what do you
make of just sort of the state of
conservatism I think that it's in a
pretty tough spot I think that what
we've done as a movement is just gone to
everything that's anti left and I don't
think that's how it should be and I
don't think that it's conservative I
think a lot of the principles I could go
issue-by-issue but there are there are a
lot of principles that I don't think are
necessarily conservative that are being
pushed forward now okay I think that
there are some things that Ronald Reagan
went support in today's time and I
actually don't think that he'd be
successful as a conservative in today's
I think people would see him as to
moderate to wishy-washy
when actually he's he's the token
conservative right and I think that that
is frustrating and I think on the
environment and every other issue the
conservative goal is to be anti Hillary
anti Bernie anti left mm-hmm and
sometimes we forget to do our own
solution and sometimes we just go the
exact opposite end of the spectrum which
is just as dangerous as whatever the far
left is proposing yeah so I think that
that's worked in Servat ism is now and I
think that is dangerous because if it
keeps going down that path
I think the first party to start
realizing that they're just going
further and further away from the truth
and the middle are the first one to
realize that and change course is gonna
have a lot of success and I hope that
conservatives can realize that and start
to come back to what conservatism truly
is which is free markets limited
government it's not just bashing the
left it's trying to work with that as
you can and it's not always a far right
policy that's gonna be the answer yeah I
think that what conservatism was in 2008
or 2012 isn't exactly ideal but it's
more it's closer to where where it
should be than it is today
and I'm not saying Trump's to blame I
think it's just a huge movement that has
been sick of the left for so long and
sick of the radicalism of the left
they've done the exact same and I think
if we could just actually stay true to
our morals and take the higher ground I
think that it would be a lot better for
the country yeah it's interesting the
way you describe that that whichever one
stops first yeah because in my view and
it's funny because we come at this from
different places right like I was a
card-carrying lefty progressive liberal
I'm obviously a little older than you
but you came at it from from the other
side and it's like for me the stuff that
I focus on I've just seen the left
implode and if anything I would say it's
basically like a train that the brakes
are off they know the cliff is coming
but they're just gonna keep going and
going and going and keep pouring coal on
and let's go off the cliff and see what
happens
don't mention coal to the library
exactly but but to me that's what I've
seen there and I really spend a lot of
my life or at least these last couple
years trying to correct that okay what I
do see and I think maybe maybe you agree
but maybe not is I
to see more fertile ground on the right
for ideas that I can now go to
libertarian events and conservative
events and they hear my differences and
they're willing to hear them out where I
see virtually none of that on the left
do you think that's a fair estimation
even though I know you're concerned
obviously about what's happening on the
on the fringes of the right I do a
certain degree I think that there is
more and I think it's a relative
statement I don't think that it's it's
enough no I don't think it's nowhere
anywhere near enough I think a perfect
example is that any conservative that
doesn't agree with Trump 100% of the
time is kind of shunned you look at it
about like CPAC or how the RNC looks at
things or something like that and I
think that what they should be doing is
embracing people of all ideologies that
come from the conservative perspective
and I think when it comes to young
people not every young person is gung-ho
for Trump not every young person is
gung-ho for a you know a wall or
whatever it may be
yeah and I think that conservatives need
to embrace the diversity more in a
leadership level I think like I college
campuses like the College Republicans
tend to be a more open and I think even
like a County Party would be more open
to different views obviously I don't
know every County Party and the millions
of counties that you have here but the
the fact that matter is I think that the
national landscape or at least the
national leaders are currently unlikely
to care about what the moderates think
or what even our typical conservative
thinks if they're not on a hundred
percent in agreement
hmm and again I think conferences kind
of show that like the the CPAC
conference and I think that's been an
issue going on for years I mean the Log
Cabin Republicans were banned from CPAC
for I don't know how many years six
years and I think that we just need to
diversify the party and that's gonna
include non-christians it's gonna
include LGBTQ people it's gonna include
minorities and it's it's gonna include
women and that's going to be the future
of the conservative party along with the
support that we have now otherwise we're
gonna be going down a very wrong track
record and if we keep shaming all those
people it's gonna be tough what part of
you doesn't say you're a libertarian
because I think I know so much
what your ideas are and you're trying to
build all those bridges I can give you a
libertarian reason for why all of those
people obviously should be included in a
conservative party or any party is there
anything about libertarian or do you
just not or is it you're just doing a
little political realism which I hear
from a lot of people is like I'm a
libertarian but the conservatives and
the Republicans are the party that I can
work with most to get those ideas I
think if that's what you just said is
probably the best answer I have the
other thing that I would say is I think
that there are I disagree with
libertarians sometimes on the level of
government that should be involved I'm
still a limited government person I also
think myself is like a Reagan
conservative but Reagan wasn't
anti-government move in a lot of ways he
increased spending sometimes he did
taxes when it was necessary again i'm
libertate government and when spending
is not possible we should never you know
we should never pursue spending if it
can be avoided same with taxes and
everything like that but I also don't
think that it's completely off the table
which some libertarians do not all um
but I think that I probably issues wise
agree more libertarians especially on
social things maybe even immigration but
I think that's some of the just but
overarching government involvement I
think the government does have a place
in some things but it should be trying
to help the people instead of push
things on the people i which i think is
is something that maybe makes me a
little bit more moderate
[Music]
you